[تصفيق]
أخيرًا كانت آرون إيزابيل
فتاة بلجيكية جميلة في باردا تشارلي نيل
غرفة معادلة ضغط الصباح المميتة gillot redha la
scintilla bwaba pharao dato mayotte شرق
اتضح أن بعضنا البعض يجعلنا قوتنا
لكراهية الدولة نعم من sarl
كامارا لاند جميع الأنواع هو الصورة
غاب عن المسلسل تماما نعم نحن
رأيته لمدة شهر لذلك نحن سعداء
لتلقي اللعبة نفتقد
التواصل مع الناس أو حتى السلطة
لتبادل القدرة على تقديم المشورة حتى نتمكن من
اللباس الذي سيحتفل به ناتي في الصباح
الطريق الجغرافي أو اليسار ولكن كلارا
كلارا ديديلويس مايكل روبيدو الخراب
تم تصوير الأخلاقية في السلطعون الذي بدأ فيه
الذنب نقول تسرعه ونفعله
صباح عندي رئيس مسلسل لكن حسب
كل من سقف سواغات
مخزن مجهز بكاميرات
عد تراه في السقف
الوصول إلى الأشخاص الذين يدخلون هذا
أنها bardou قد سرد النار الناعمة
منجم داتي لا تفعل شيئًا في وضع جول
farré خصومات الولاء و
رد فعل ولكن الخيول لاحظت لي مين